Speaker Nancy Pelosi melting down after
plowing ahead with articles of
impeachment and Joe Biden blowing up on
a man who dared to ask about his sons
Ukraine connections but first Pelosi
claims the facts against President Trump
are uncontested and says Democrats will
hold another hearing Monday Pelosi
snapping at a reporter when making the
announcement as a Catholic I resent your
using the word hate in a sentence that
addresses me I don't hate anyone I pray
for the president all the time so don't
mess with me when it comes to words like
that woo President Trump firing right
back telling Democrats that if they're
going to impeach they need to do it fast
and while that's going down the big
thing that's getting attention is this
moment from yesterday's hearing the
Constitution says there can be no titles
of nobility so while the president can
name his son Baron he can't make him a
baron Melania blasting the professor
saying she should be ashamed all right
Greg thoughts feelings oh all right
where to start you could have a show
trial at least make it interesting
this makes c-span look like MMA I mean I
honestly the only excitement I could get
out of this is wondering why we're
covering it okay this has been a
continuous orchestration for three years
right we knew that this is happening yet
we're obliged to act like this is news
right oh look there are gavels right oh
it's in a courtroom it's in a hearing
room there are cameras that are
politicians there appear to be expert
witnesses who have witnessed nothing but
yet we must treat them as though there
are witnesses we have to sit there and
know that the Democrats are yanking our
chains they are basically playing the
little piano and we're dancing like
little chimps and it drives me nuts
watching this but I have to that's why I
don't blame the Democrats I don't blame
them for this because we're just helping
them out this is a media induced coup if
we decided when that woman made that
joke if we decided
okay the Republicans should have just
got up in a laugh that would have been
great and then if we decided to stop
covering it that would have been amazing
and by the way the joke isn't the
problem it's it's just it's a joke we
make jokes it's that's our um the
problem is that it was planned it was
rehearsed it was choreographed she knew
she was among friends she knew that she
was going to get laughter by the way
these hearings now are Trump rallies for
the media because they can't fill arenas
but they can fill those hearings with
so-called experts this is their way and
we get played by it the network's get
played and we have salt our viewers with
this crap
1 2 Greg's point the Democrats can't
compete with Trump so they have to
produce this theater impeachment is the
only thing that can technically compete
with Donald Trump so they can't beat
them they can't cooperate with them
because I don't want it so they have to
play the impeachment card and I don't
think it's working I think it's
completely backfiring
what didn't Greg just say you know it's
a preordained reality they're going to
impeach him and so it wasn't that
interesting Greg's argument was it was
kind of boring to even sit there and
watch here are some experts and like so
it's not competing with Trump the
showman I don't think that's the kill
its shucking up all of the energy in the
grow I think it reflects to cover it Wan
well that's what you just yet that's
what I'm saying okay that's what I know
that it's not a setup because look I
think that Democrats have the votes to
impeach I think that's what Nancy Pelosi
announced today when she said we're
going to go ahead the facts are on their
side they're undisputed well I'll tell
you what most fair-minded people think
that the facts are pretty clear so John
Charlie hang on was it fair-minded can I
finish please in the Fox poll 49%
impeach and remove 60% number hang on
60% say it's a safety be health
can I finish it's the Fox poll it says
60% say he held up military aid in order
to get a favor the ABC post 70% say what
he did was wrong hold on I tell you what
you know what's really crazy John Durham
apparently Cory the Washington Post not
able to produce anything
says oh this was the Washington put home
my god was a Russian yeah yeah listen to
every you said wait for the IG Michael
Horowitz wait for John to okay we did oh
yes he scheduled the hearing on Monday
the day the IG Charlet way by the way
where's your boy Julia and everybody on
he's over in the Ukraine still doing
this and you want to close your you mean
fingering Biden for kuroh yeah over in
the usually mad because suicide mission
because it's gonna come you're now
moving from quid pro quo
to what bribery now abuse of power
what's next on the structure of justice
yes obstruction funny yeah it's gonna
come back and hit the Democrats cuz
they're guilty of abuse of power
oh the biggest tell is for me in the
most confusing part of it is that for
the for the Democrats saying that they
needed all evidence that this is in fact
a deliberate process where they care
about a thorough fact-finding segment
and then an actual analysis why the rush
why when justice is supposed to move at
the pace that it requires to get all of
the evidence and all of a sudden the
Democrats do not care about the McGann
testimony and they do not care about the
Muller grand jury testimony both of
which the court proceedings are
happening in January all of a sudden
there's this massive rush as an attorney
I am so confused by that and as a
citizen I think it's the biggest tell
you know by the way all the attorneys
are confused you can't even get
attorneys to agree on this because
they're asking people's opinions about
something in which they haven't
witnessed it I'm sorry okay issues so
January 3rd both of those hearings are
gonna be held at the the DC Circuit
which is one step below the Supreme
Court which is a lot of this stuff may
end up there anyway but their court
arguments and documents are they need
the McGann testimony and they need the
grand jury documents from Muller because
it's essential to the impeachment so
they're making that argument at the same
time they're not willing to wait for the
ruling on that and as to whether the
facts are in dispute or not I actually
think that most everyone does agree on
the facts what they don't agree on or
what the facts meet because people are
saying like look we have the transcript
and the president says look it and
there's nothing I'm not trying to hide
anything here the Democrats will look at
that same transcript and say this is why
we're impeached but I think first hang
on Sunday night into yard
all right cool situations how do you
think he was okay you know I I mean I
kind of like a feisty Biden no I wasn't
sleepy that wasn't sleepy I but we might
be singing another side of Biden Joe
woke up on what do you think well I'm
interested to see their response because
you guys love it when Trump goes off on
people I didn't even think he went off
on that guy I think he responded to a
difficult question for him about his son
and he did so emphatically and I think
that helps his campaign do you think he
did so passionately at the same event
Biden called someone fat and Jack vice
president in 1976 and he called all of
those voters who were in Iowa that they
said they were in Ohio oh wow in
addition to all of those good fact that
he responded clearly out of anger he has
to have a better answer because those
questions are pretty basic idea he has
to have a measured response when he's no
better than Trump so he claims that's
out of control I'm not a big crowd there
either no I'm worried for that guy
though because remember I'm buying said
not long ago that had he been in high
school with President Trump he would
have taken it behind the gym gym and
beaten the quote hell out of him so this
guy you better watch his stuff I mean
the pickup contests maybe the ladder did
you just use the word hell it was I know
you said it was a quote but still I
don't think that's nice for shannon
bream especially on the 5 which is a
clean clean show a family-friendly show
Joe this is this is not after 11:00
you know what joke did that was good
well I was when they asked him about I
don't know where this was but they asked
him about Kamala Harris and he and you
hold a grudge or something like that and
he says I'm not good at holding grudges
which is a really nice answer it's a
smart answer I can't grip them very hard
he said he also may consider hook for
the ticket I'm sure she's overjoyed by
that yes yes well you know what that's
our way into the White House we've been
talking about she's going to the White
House and one way yes